so Monday night Bernie Sanders did a
town hall event one hour long on CNN a
number of different presidential
candidates have been doing them so far
and in general there's always sort of a
discussion and people end up unhappy
about who gets to ask questions at these
events and at this particular Town Hall
there's more anger than usual because
the assertion is that a lot of the
people who got to ask questions weren't
accurately represented as the political
operatives or lobbyists associated
individuals that they were so I'm going
to lay out the facts here and then we
can kind of think through what the
implications are whether we should be
upset and at whom because originally the
claim was all of these secret operatives
were planted in order to make Bernie
look bad but it actually seems to be a
little bit more nuanced than that
so we get the Bernie's Town Hall and
I'll go through a few of these examples
and at one point a young woman gets up
to ask a question about sexual
harassment not being taken seriously by
Bernie Sanders during his 2016 campaign
and the question was very scripted which
is fine people tend to plan their
questions out ahead of time and then CNN
decides who gets to ask them but what
people are upset about is that the woman
was identified as an American University
student when in fact although that
appears to be true she's also an intern
at a Washington DC lobbying firm named
Cassidy and associates her name is Adina
sob check out the question check out
just a little bit of Bernie's answer we
have a question from shadi nosov a
student at American University Shaunie's
from Denver as we saw in the 2018
midterms the Democratic Party has become
more female more racially diverse and
younger in age how can a voter like me
feel confident in your ability to
represent the party especially given
that your response to sexual harassment
allegations during your campaign is that
you were quote a little bit busy running
around the country trying to make the
case to be elected as president well I
think that quote was a little bit out of
context but let me ask you a question I
am enormous ly proud of the fact that we
have the most diverse progressive
freshmen
in the history of the United States
Congress and you know what I did in 2016
and in 2018 I ran all over this country
to try to make that happen
all right so when you talk about the
political revolution you're talking
about two things number one are the
ideas that we are fighting for an
economy that works for all not just the
1% but the second point that I have made
over and over again is we're not going
to be able to implement a progressive
agenda unless millions more people get
involved in the political process yeah
so Bernie answers it perfectly well he
then goes on to say it was very painful
that those allegations were made okay
very quickly people started looking
around and saying okay shadi and Assad
it says on CNN that she's an American
University student turns out she's a
public policy intern at this lobbyist
Cassady and associates and people were
able to confirm this by looking at her
LinkedIn Cassady and associates is an
establishment DC lobbying firm it's
connected to Democratic Minority Leader
Harry Reid's former deputy chief of
staff former Minority Leader who's
currently the CEO they worked for the
Egyptian government to improve Egypt's
image in the u.s. after news of Egyptian
human rights abuses surfaced they were
actually sort of involved in a number of
different political issues and the
argument was this is a plant from an
establishment firm to smear Bernie with
this question but it's not totally clear
that that's when it was the other
argument that has been made is this was
someone who simply teed up for Bernie a
really great opportunity to deal with
the sexual assault sexual harassment
allegations so the question really for
me is are these individuals being
presented in the way that most reflects
their presence at the Town Hall I'll
give you some other examples of this
here's one other one Tara Eversole okay
Tara Eversole was listed as a former
biology professor when she asked a
question if you look at her LinkedIn
profile yes she used to be a bi all
professor but right now she's the chair
of the Baltimore County Democratic Party
she's a political operative she's not
just some random former biology
professor now does that tell us whether
her presence is in order to antagonize
Bernie from an establishment point of
view or to help Bernie no it doesn't it
just tells us that the room is filled
with political operatives rather than
just random disinterested voters other
than wanting to figure out who to vote
for another example a woman named Avena
McAllister Avena McAllister presented as
a mother of two and I'm sure she is a
mother of two but according to the
Charles County Democratic Central
Committee website
she is a democratic committee member she
has a formal position within a local
Democratic Party and I could go on and
on and on there's a whole long list of
these so the question is what does it
matter what does it matter
initially the allegation was CNN
participated in stacking the room with
anti Bernie people to smear him then
people started thinking a little bit
more in a nuanced way about this and
what is the most likely scenario to me
Pat and you tell me if you disagree is
that anytime there's one of these town
halls everybody who has an interest and
that is going to be disproportionately
political groups political operatives
lobbyists etc they try to get their
people in the room obviously they would
try to do that so I think that if
anybody is at fault here it's number one
CNN for maybe not doing enough to get
actual just regular voters in the room
and number two the titles that these
people were assigned I think are
deceptive I totally agree I blame CNN
not getting the right titles or at least
the appropriate titles and I think we
are on edge here and we have the right
to be because Bernie Sanders was screwed
in 2016 not just by the DNC but also by
the establishment media right they
didn't cover his rallies at the
beginning they didn't cover his campaign
meanwhile they were covering Donald
Trump's empty podium and you know had
plenty of interest in Hillary Clinton so
we don't want to see that happen again
in 2020
no and I think a lot of the discussion
about this is wrongly about debating the
merits of a question about sexual
assault because as soon as you argue
that this was a planted shill from a
lobbying group to smear Bernie about
sexual assault
you then have to defend that the sexual
assault questions not valid and while I
agree that sadena Saabs framing was not
a complete framing sexual assault in
campaigns particularly if you're talking
about women's rights and gender equality
it's a perfectly legitimate question so
for me it's less about pointing to that
question as a smear or a softball I
don't know exactly what that particular
lobbying firms interests are in this
election they may well be establishment
and they may be trying to hurt Bernie or
not I just don't know we don't know
exactly what their role is right now
this is sort of breaking news how
candidates deal with sexual assault
matters the question was incorrectly
framed Bernie Sanders answered the
question to the best of his ability
overall what we have to understand is
that this is calculated theater for
television and the sources that have
money are going to disproportionately
have control over the discourse that's
really the message CNN has an interest
in selecting from the questions that are
submitted the ones that they think are
going to be most interesting and
relevant and Cain's a case in point this
question from a lobbyist in turn was
selected to be clipped separately on
CNN's website so CNN has a role to play
lobbying groups and Democratic Party
groups and others know what types of
questions are more likely to be selected
so this is a sort of systemic reality
and focusing on this one question is
relevant but I think it misses the
bigger point there were lots of fluff
softballs during Kamala Harris's Town
Hall many of them were were sort of out
of context or lacking criticism does
that mean that the entire thing was
designed to prop up Kamala Harris maybe
if you believe that the DNC has already
sort of selected her but it could very
much be more a reflection
of the mechanisms that lead to what
questions are written down by people and
how CNN selects them I think what we can
all come away with an agree upon is that
a one-hour town hall which with such
carefully curated questions and no real
opportunity for a back-and-forth doesn't
really give us too much of an
opportunity to learn about the candidate
that's my main complaint one of the
day's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy comm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link